Did you guys learn anything from working with each other?
What was like a fly on the wall moment
that you guys can give me about each other?
Well.
I feel like I learned so many things working with Melanie.
I think she's a genius,
and just one of these incredible incredible people.
Number one, amazing human, number two amazing artist.
But I think the thing I remember most
about working with you Mel
is your ability to be so still
and so powerful at the same time.
I find working with her
like watching this channel happening
it's very impressive.
I.
Totally agree with that.
I'm gonna cry.
(Melanie laughs)
Okay Melanie, what was one thing that surprised you
or you took away from within with Jessica?
Well I've been a fan of hers for years and years.
And I think that she's been so underrated
because people don't wanna believe
that you can look like that and be as talented as she is.
And I really think that this one
is the one that everyone's just gonna be,
she's one of our great actors,
she's one of the greatest actors I've ever worked with.
(audience clapping)
Who is honestly.
Now you're gonna make me cry, stop it.
Thank you.
You have so much to celebrate.
Speaking of celebration, Jessica you just had a birthday.
I did, I did yes.
Tell us everything.
(Jessica laughs)
What did you do?
What was the scene?
Set the stage.
Okay.
Well I actually thought nothing was happening,
I thought we were gonna,
my husband I were planning something for the summer.
And then he completely surprised me
with an incredible party with my friends from Montana
where we were at the time.
And.
He flew his band in and he played for me,
he played, my kids made me that cake
and these beautiful cards.
And then he played this whole show for me,
all covers sort of the songs of our life together,
all the songs that we love and have been listening to
for the last, gosh we've been together for 14 years
or 15 years or something now
and married for almost 10 (audience clapping)
which is crazy.
It was so amazing and it was such a good surprise,
and I love surprises so he knows that about me.
I love it,
he played covers of the soundtracks of your lives.
And Melanie.
(Jessica laughs) I know.
Your husband is just, Jason Ritter he's so wonderful,
he's an incredible actor,
he seems like the most wonderful person,
(audience clapping) I've met him a few times.
And you guys seem
like you love each other so much it's ridiculous.
We do, we do love each other (Melanie laughs) so much
I can't deny it.
I'm so glad and happy that both of you are crushing it
in life and in the show.
You're both on fire.
(upbeat music)